[Music]
so when one country intervenes and in
other countries civil war one of the
things that happens is it extends the
war and if you think about it what's
happening is that you're having more
resources coming into that conflict and
it's bringing in your resources bringing
in new interests basically complicating
and complexify in that war that was
already a very complex war there are
ways in which intervention might be good
which is you're trying to pull the
parties apart not trying to pick sides
one side picking the other side and and
that can sort of stop the killing but
typically before that happens if outside
states are getting involved in a civil
war it tends to extend it so history is
mixed on how to best solve civil wars it
turns out that the international
community has a strong proclivity toward
negotiated settlements so you want the
parties to both lay down their arms and
negotiate an end to the civil war where
each of them feels as if they have a
part to play in the configuration of the
new state that is the absolute
preference that the international
community has and it pushes to that we
are pushing for that today in Syria
Afghanistan there's now a discussion
about negotiating with the Taliban
because we understand we may not be able
to force an end to this war and that the
Taliban are not going anywhere and that
we might not what you might have to
negotiate with them the problem is in
order for a negotiated settlement to to
resolve a civil war requires both sides
to stay absolutely committed to that and
to remain committed to that for a long
time and that requires for both sides or
if it was more than one side you can
think about the former wars in
Yugoslavia more than one side that if
they renege on the negotiated settlement
that it's going to be harmful to them
and to their interests so you want to be
thinking about how to ensure that both
sides are all sides feel compelled to
stay aligned with what the negotiated
settlement brought in order to end the
war and one way to do that is to ensure
that the security service the Armed
Forces are configured correctly and that
they're representative of the broader
nation another way is to have outside
peacekeepers there to keep the parties
apart so you can think about the former
Yugoslavia or even Cyprus there are
peacekeepers there and they've been
there now for decades in both places and
they were supposed to be there for one
year bill President Bill Clinton said we
are only going to be there for a year
and that was in 1995 it's now 2017 and
similarly in Cyprus in the 1970s
peacekeepers were supposed to be there
temporarily and they're there somewhat
permanently the good news is you haven't
had many deaths as a result because the
peacekeepers have kept them apart so
negotiated settlements are one way to
sort of end Wars and to keep them all
ended but actually they're quite there
they're not the most common an
alternative is thinking about military
victories which end today about half of
civil wars prior to the end of the Cold
War they ended three-quarters of all
civil wars so a military victory just
means that one side prevails on the
battlefield and it turns out
historically that they're more robust
that one one side wins and prevails in
civil war you're more likely to have a
longer lasting settlement and the
question is why is that
so I've researched that and it turns out
I believe the reason is is because to
reason it turns out that rebel victories
are even more robust one is is that by
defeating the other side you've
demonstrated that you have the capacity
to defeat the other side right that you
actually have the military might so when
you think about those negotiated
settlements that's what a third party is
providing is the capacity to keep the
players apart and secondarily
particularly when it comes to rebel
victories why they're more robust is
they have legitimacy so they defeated
the government and they usually can
bring the population behind them to
support the configuration and the
running of the new government and in
fact the rebels quite often bring
opposition into government in order to
more effectively govern so military
victories are an option they have been
an option historically the issue is the
international community sort of doesn't
support it because it sounds as if we're
advocating the use of force or the
continued use of force I'm a pragmatist
when it comes to these kinds of things I
look at the international community and
where it wants to go and whether it
wants to go into different corners of
the world and it's not willing to go
into every corner of the world the
international community particularly
large actors the Soviet Union in the old
days now Russia and the United States
and its allies
aren't going to go everywhere so they're
not going to commit to bringing peace to
every corner of the world think about
Myanmar today and there were hinga being
targeted Myanmar has had a number of
civil wars raging for a number of years
but the international community does not
have the will to go in there and
negotiate separate pieces to bring peace
to that country and therefore we have to
acknowledge and recognize that military
victories are out there they have
concluded civil wars most recently they
concluded to one with Sri Lanka where
the government prevailed over the Tamil
Tigers after decades of fighting and now
yes it was a horrific end to that civil
war there's no denying it there were
fears of genocide but now the
international community can step in and
say to the Sri Lankan government you
need to treat the Tamil population
equitably fairly justly and perhaps work
with the Sri Lankan government to have
them behave to not sort of take out
vengeance revenge against that that the
Tamil population and then the other one
is South Sudan with South Sudan it was
actually a rebel victory and basically
that was a rebel victory that resulted
in the partition and the creation of a
new state which again partition is quite
rare the international community doesn't
support the idea of making new states in
part because most states in the
international system are multinational
and multi-ethnic and they don't want to
set that precedent of allowing one state
to have in one state to allow for pieces
of it to break off and because they fear
that it will set off a set of domino
it's not only within their own state but
but globally so so victory is a
possibility as well as negotiated
settlements and when I look at these
cases historically and then also
contemporaneously what I'm looking at is
is there a will in the capacity of the
international community to get involved
and if there's not then we might want to
countenance victory for one side of the
other who are the good guys who the bad
guys honestly in most civil wars does a
little bit of bad on both in some cases
a lot of bad on one side a little bit
about on another and so you want to look
at
the conditions about whether victory is
even a possibility and then negotiated
settlement is there a commitment from
one party the United Nations a coalition
of states to go in and just help keep
the peace or to make peace and then help
keep the peace later because without
that commitment it's very hard for the
parties to not be susceptible to
fighting down the road it turns out if
you have one Civil War your chance is
the biggest indicator if you have had a
civil war in the past your chances of
having another Civil War is much greater
[Music]